[Música]
bueno voy a empezar con un cuento que
creo que todos sabrán los más jóvenes
también de hansel y gretel esto está
relacionado con lo que pasé y viví con
mi esposo el creador de esto el
investigador
así como los chicos es un día fueron al
bosque y descubrieron con sorpresa esta
casita de
de galletitas de dulces de confites de
chocolate bueno eso se hizo realidad en
el laboratorio de la facultad de
ingeniería forestal con el ingeniero
roberto pascutti
mi esposo roberto pascutti y yo vinimos
en el año 70 a esta hermosa tierra la
tierra colorada de la cual nos
enamoramos él más que yo de la tierra
está
yo como profesora de inglés él como
docente nato ingeniero y luego estudió
en la facultad de ciencias de ingeniería
forestal del dorado siempre investigando
siempre amando el bosque y siempre
viendo el bosque como un recurso
alimentario
yo sabía que estaba investigando porque
siempre estaba investigando siempre
estaba curioseando investigando y un día
de ahí el relato del cuento nos invita a
ir al bosque vamos me dijo te quiero
mostrar algo
bueno en el claro del bosque me dice que
ves y bueno yo veo árboles hojas plantas
por ahí un helecho un buen ve una liana
y no no pero que ves y eso de otra cosa
lo veo no enfrente tuyo que ves bueno
había un árbol 15 metros de altura muy
erguido me dice este es el árbol el
sacar atea
desde ese momento sacar a tía y madera
comestible entro en mi vida y en la mía
en la de mi familia
nosotros también participamos o somos
yacaratiá que este árbol porque
investigo este árbol esto comienza con
los guaraníes él observaba a los
guaraníes que comían unas largas esas
largas ellos las comían en fogones o sea
las hacían las hadas este árbol tiene 90
por ciento de agua por lo tanto son
árboles maderables es un árbol amigable
al medio ambiente hay femenina y
masculino por lo tanto su hábitat con
muchísimo orgullo a pesar de que aunque
mis hijas son misioneras y yo ya me
considero misionera solamente crece en
el centro y norte de la provincia de
misiones muy poquitito así alrededor es
su hábitat natural crece en los jardines
en las calles en las plazas y así es que
nosotros no plantamos árboles sino es
que nos llaman tomando mi gente a buscar
porque a veces están los jardines y está
creciendo tan alto que molesta
y ahí lo rescatamos para convertirlo en
ese producto gourmet que mi esposo con
años de investigación logro
esto llevó mucho esfuerzo más un
científico saben que dinero no
precisamente era lo que menos había
había que sacar el análisis así que fue
todos sus colegas sus compañeros sus
amigos su familia probábamos
continuamente la madera los diferentes
productos que iba haciendo que iba
logrando
hasta que bueno tuvimos que ir a buenos
aires él comenzó a gestionar la patente
intelectual lo cual fue bastante arduo
costoso muchísimos análisis de todo tipo
lo logró yo siempre lo acompañé porque
yo lo ayudaba en la parte de inglés de
traducciones que él hacía libros y
también acompañándolo siempre en la
investigación aparte yo tenía mi trabajo
bueno después de eso
hubo que ponerlo en el código
alimentario nacional grave problema como
nos decían y como ponemos comemos madera
madera se come que que qué nombre le
ponemos fue todo un problema o sea
porque como se denomina es algo no
convencional aún muchos de ustedes no la
conocen
muchísima gente tampoco la conoce bueno
eso se logró empezaron los
reconocimientos
y cámaras de diputados cámaras de
senadores nosotros seguíamos social
seguía trabajando hasta que llegó lo que
yo diría un orgullo para él para
nosotros que fue participar en kuala
lumpur malasia
de entre los estuvo entre los ocho
proyectos mejores internacionales
forestales y luego recibió un premio de
la ingeniería de academia internacional
de marco wallenberg en suecia todo hasta
ahí y vamos despacito pero íbamos él
fallece y ahí entró yo
la gran pregunta mía era qué hacía con
todo esto que hacía con todo lo que me
había dejado con todo lo que había
aprendido con todo con todo que hacía
con todo esto las manos y si va a poder
ser capaz adelante de un aula me sentía
segura yo daba inglés en las empresas
era segura pero
el comercio entre mi hija con la cual
estoy trabajando
es como propietaria de esta empresa pyme
familiar y me dijo te parece mamá nos
largamos yo te apoyo bueno y bueno dije
yo nos largamos
ella me impuso o sea me impuso no puso
esa parte de juventud de riesgo de
creatividad y yo puse toda la parte de
investigación todo lo que mi esposo me
había enseñado
empezamos despacito y como empezamos
empezamos en las ferias empezamos a ir a
las ferias de palermo caminos y sabores
porque se sabe que buenos aires ahí está
todo
el primer año fue fantástico pero
fantástico con con episodios porque se
agolpaban en nuestro stand y muchos
decían no eso no es madera no se puede
comer madera entonces había que explicar
explicar explicar que sí que se puede
comer madera y que acá está
otros decían no me voy a quedar sin
dientes no se me van a romper los
dientes no nosotros los tenemos todos
ponemos madera mis nietos estaban por
los pasillos haciendo degustación de
madera otros nos decían bush la pucha ya
nos vamos a volver termitas o sea
teníamos miles de cosas bueno todo eso a
medida que fueron los años lo mejor de
todo esto aparte de conocer fue que se
empezaron a integrar los chefs como en
palermo hay cocinas entonces los chef
empezaron a ver este producto como un
producto no convencional un producto
diríamos no convencional un producto
ahora muy fibroso un producto que no es
fácil para que ellos lo puedan cocinar
así comenzaron un chef de misiones
provinciales internacionales y los
comenzaron a llevar a todos los lugares
hoy están perú en mexico
no puedo nombrarlos a los chefs porque
tengo una relación muy grande amistosa
con ellos y por ahí me olvido de alguno
entonces sánchez de misiones muy
reconocidos chefs nacionales muy
reconocidos muchos de ellos vinieron acá
nos fuimos al monte con una olla
buscamos un árbol machete amos entramos
al monte no lo que hemos hecho no se
imaginan pero acá en eldorado en
misiones porque la madera o sea el
dorado es cuna de la madera eso mi
esposo siempre me lo dijo y yo lo
mantengo y es así
bueno ellos empezaron a hacer exquisitas
es de la madera empezamos a hablar con
más productores siempre de a poco de a
poco creciendo y teniendo un sueño que
lo compartíamos con mi esposo
tener un lugar porque la gente quiere
saber cómo es la madera ustedes hay en
la pantalla
las tablas blancas cuando viene la
madera cortada está llamando la gente a
cortar al monte
o sea todo eso lo va aprendiendo
quieren saber tocar la tienda
no tiene el sabor no tiene por ahora no
tiene
para la investigación
de cómo y de las hojas donde se hace de
los días que se cocinan
entonces nosotros dijimos bueno al
turista que viene acá al dorado a la
gente al turista internacional que
vienen en colectivos así que uno les
explica yo hablando inglés eso me ayuda
mucho sea algo de italiano por mi marido
que era italiano entonces éste le
mostramos cómo se hace de donde nace el
que está acá en el dorado vuelvo a
repetir que es único en el mundo porque
es el único árbol que se puede comer no
hay otro algo no contiene celulosa
entonces es un orgullo enorme esté acá
que crezca en nuestra tierra y se le
explica todo eso a la gente y es
sorprendente ver cuando prueban la
madera para mí eso me pasa casi todos
los días y todos los días no dejo de
sorprenderme
hoy se no puede ser es así es y otros
dicen tienes gusto esto bueno no es ni
ni ni ni decimos
bueno creamos un 'showroom' en el cual
hay todo un vidrio en el cual se ve cómo
se hace la madera después damos
degustación y eso es algo que nos
permite difundir y que la gente vea
todo esto fueron muchos años quince años
de trabajo arduo
sin mucho dinero
y bueno fuimos logrando cosas hoy
estamos exportando en pequeñas
cantidades no demasiado
y seguimos con proyectos que vamos a ver
con pequeños proyectos que nos vamos
poniendo día a día no grandes cosas
que les puedo decir después de todo esto
qué
que si pude que se puede que de un aula
pase un comercio que me equivoque que
tuve aciertos que tuvo errores que aún
tengo equivocaciones pero logré poder
hacerlo si tengo a mi hija que es una
gran ayuda lógicamente y mi familia que
siempre está ayudando a mis nietos
orgullosos que andan por todos lados con
la más dura es más les cuento algo
íntimo yo suelo viajar entonces me
acuerdo que en uno de los viajes teníais
en la muy buena relación con un grupito
de señoras
y bueno a los dos o tres días me
preguntan qué hago y a mí me sale
espontáneamente hago madera comestible y
no me creyeron que estaba haciéndoles
una broma y al otro día nadie me habló
entonces ahora cada vez que viajo llevo
mi folleto donde tenemos la página y
cuando no me creen acá está vea la
página investiguen y van a ver que sí es
cierto bueno esta es la historia esta es
la manera comestible
los invito a que vean la página
esta esta soy yo ya karate a
delicatessen y bueno en los que les
cuento es lo que hasta allí puedo creo
contarles para no hacerlo más largo
gracias
[Música]